welcome to the presentation on level two
exponents
level two exponents the only thing we're
going to add to the mix now is the
concept of a negative exponent so we
learned already that two to the third
power well that just equals two times
two times two hopefully by now that's
second nature to you and that equals
eight now I'm going to teach you what
two to the negative third power is now I
know a lot of you're going to say oh no
that's negative eight but whenever you
see exponents you always have to
remember you're remind yourself
exponents are not multiplication and I
know there's that temptation to say well
two times negative three is negative six
so maybe two to the negative third power
is negative eight but that's not the
case and I'll explain in a future module
why we use this convention but two to
the negative third power it turns out is
equivalent to 1/2 to the third power so
it turns out the negative exponent what
it does is it means to take the inverse
of the base we'll call number two as a
base and take that to the positive
version of the exponent and 1/2 to the
third power well we already learned
that's 1/2 times 1/2 times 1/2 and that
equals 1/8 so we say 2 to the negative
third power that didn't come out right 2
to the negative third power is equal to
1/8 let's do another one let's say 3 to
the negative 2 power
once again immediately when we see that
negative in the exponent the easiest
thing to do is just immediately take the
reciprocal of the base so we take
one-third and we raise that to the
positive 2 power and that's easy now 1/3
squared well that's equal to 1 1 over 9
let's do some more problems
what if I had 2 over 3 2 over 3 to the
negative third power well once again
just to make it simple whenever I see
that negative in the exponent I want to
get rid of it so I immediately take I
take the reciprocal of the base the
reciprocal of 2/3 is 3 over 2 and I
raise that to the positive 3rd power so
what changed between the left on the
right side the 2 over 3 I flipped and I
attend the negative 3 into a positive 3
and now this just becomes a level 1
exponent this equals three-halves times
three-halves times three-halves and that
equals 27 over 8 so that's interesting
2/3 to the negative 3 is equal to 27
over 8 let's do some more let's do 4
over 7 to the negative 1 once again we
have a negative number in the exponent
that's the same thing as taking the
reciprocal of the base and raising it to
the positive exponent
well 7/4 to the 1 the number to the
first power is just the same number it's
equal to 7/4 so we take U to the
negative 1 power all you're essentially
doing is getting the reciprocal of the
number let's do some more problems 2 to
the negative 5 once again we take the
reciprocal of 2 and we say 1 over 2 now
that will can be raised to the fifth
power and that equals 1/2 times 1/2
times 1/2 times 1/2 times 1/2 and that
equals 1 over 32 another way we could
have viewed 2 to the negative 5th is
that 2 to the negative 5th we could have
said that equals 1 over 2 to the 5th and
we know that 2 to the 5th is 32 so that
would have been the same thing two ways
to do it pretty much just changing the
order when you flip verses when you
actually calculate the exponent let me
do two or three more problems and after
I write down each of these problems you
might just want to pause it and see if
you can do the problem yourself and then
compare your answer to mine so let's say
I had negative 4 to the negative third
power immediately I like to get rid of
the negative in the exponent and I know
that that equals minus 1 over 4 to the
third power well that equals minus 1
over 4 times minus 1 over 4 times minus
1 over 4 the negative times a negative
is a positive
we're going to be multiplying that times
another negative so we get a negative 1
times 1 times 1 is 1 4 times 4 16 times
4 is 64 so it equals negative 6 negative
1 64 let's do another problem
let me think of a good number eight over
nine let's make it negative negative 8
over 9 to the negative 2nd power
well once again that equals negative 9
over 8 notice I just immediately just
took the reciprocal reciprocal of the
base and to the positive 2 power and now
that equals negative 9 over 8 times
negative 9 over 8 a negative times a
negative is a positive
so we get 9 times 9 is 81 over 64 I
think you get the point now the only new
thing we've learned really is that when
you have a negative exponent it's the
same thing as taking the reciprocal of
the base and raising it to the positive
exponent
hopefully that last statement didn't
didn't confuse you more it did more good
than damage but I think you're ready to
try some problems now have fun